Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this morning
I asked you all to submit Doctor Who questions
so this video will be all about those.
Most of you are really curious about Capaldi’s
catchphrase or big characters returning.
Thankfully Moffat has explained a little about
some of this that I’ll mention when we get
going.
Quick congrats to Brad Miller, you’re this
week’s giveaway winner.
It’s an amazon giftcard.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
Next round of the giveaway starts when I post
my Classic Who video later this week.
That might end up being Saturday, maybe sooner
if I can get through a few other videos.
Remember all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment.
So on to questions, Number 1 - The Doctor’s
Assistant asks What was your first episode
of Doctor Who?
The first one I can remember consiously planning
on watching was Eleventh Hour the first time
it aired.
My family was more Star Wars and Lord of the
Rings growing up so I didn’t discover Doctor
Who until well after the 2005 reboot.
I think it was one of the science fiction
blogs I read at the time hyping it up before
Matt Smith’s debut so I decided to check
it out and fell in love with it.
I’ll say that I ended up liking series 6
the most just because the cast had gotten
a lot more comfortable in their clothes so
to speak, they were more of a family and I
was much more personally invested in the story
at that point.
Series 7 felt a bit weird just because of
the big mid-season break.
I think I circled back around to watch Eccleston
and Tennant’s episodes sometime during Series
6.
And then slowly started watching classic who.
There’s still a ton of stuff I haven’t
seen.
But I can very clearly remember what I felt
like, what my apartment looked like, what
I was thinking about when Eleventh Hour was
getting ready to premiere.
Question 2 - Keegen Bezenah asks when you
do videos for the episodes could you point
out easter eggs if you see them?
I’ll definitely try to catch as much as
possible, but the more Classic Who you’ve
watched the better your chances are for seeing
things.
Most of the stuff I mention will probably
be the really clear stuff.
But sometimes Doctor Who actors will make
some subtle choice in a scene that is a reference
but is so subtle you barely notice it.
I’m trying to figure out a way for you guys
to message me with easter eggs you see that
I missed.
If there’s stuff you guys find I want to
give you credit.
So stay tuned, once I think of an organized
way to handle that I’ll let you all know
so you can participate.
Question 3 - Chrisy Smith asks Do you think
that Clara will stick around or will the changes
scare her off?
I think episode 1 will handle most of the
Clara gets used to Capaldi.
The hurdle she has to jump over is the Doctor
not being the Doctor as she knows him.
So there relationship has to adapt.
That might be why Moffat included Vastra in
the episode.
She’s always been a neutral figure in the
Doctor’s life.
Someone who is long-lived like he is and has
a much broader perspective on the matter.
Most companions only know one version of the
Doctor, some get to see the new one after
the regeneration like Sarah Jane.
It will definitely be weird but I think she’ll
adapt pretty fast.
Question 4 - Edward asks do you think Clara
will reference Matt Smith’s Doctor a lot
or is he done and gone?
Yes, she’ll still be thinking Matt Smith
when she’s thinking of the Doctor.
Capaldi will be like an abstract idea.
Like seeing your friend in cosplay.
I don’t know how long she’ll keep referring
to past events with the Doctor but I think
after the first few episodes she’ll speak
more in present tense and less in past tense.
There’s rumors about a Matt Smith phone
call in the first episode.
If that’s true, that would be the big hurdle
they cross before they get on with their new
lives.
There was a clip from episode 2 that’s been
turned into gif’s on tumblr.
Based on the jokes in that I think that Matt
Smith references will largely be limited to
the first episode.
But every time the Doctor runs into a character
we haven’t seen for a long time they’ll
probably have that quick moment where the
person isn’t sure who they’re looking
at till the Doctor says something familiar.
Question 5 - Cailan Cook asks are there going
to be any Two Parters this year?
Yes, the finale is two parts.
I don’t remember where I saw it but I think
Moffat claimed the stories would be less serialized
this year too.
Meaning there would be more one-off episodes.
It makes sense they’d do that for Capaldi’s
first run.
It’s a lot easier for new viewers to jump
on a series if they don’t have to know a
lot of details from earlier episodes.
They kind of did the same thing with series
5.
Once they got to series 6 though the River
Song Lake Silencio plot took up most of the
story.
Question 6 - Mario Hernandez asks do you think
Capaldi will use a lot of previous Doctor’s
catchphrases in the episode?
I’ve heard there’s a very signature Tom
Baker catchphrase but I think he’ll do a
bit from all the Doctor’s, some references
will be more obvious than others but Capaldi’s
Doctor is supposed to be closer to the third
and fourth doctors than any of the others.
That will tie in with the easter eggs and
references I was talking about.
If you guys see certain things you can just
message me and I’ll add it to my episode
videos.
I know a lot of you have been asking what
I think Capaldi’s catchphrase will end up
being and I don’t know but I’d love it
if there was a little bit of Malcolm Tucker
in it.
I don’t think the BBC would let him swear
that much but I think we’ll see some pretty
amazing tumblr edits when people start posting
gif sets of the episodes.
Question 7 - Alec Plumley asks I watched Tennant’s
run but do I need to watch Matt Smith’s
run to understand what’s going on?
Good question, no you don’t but it will
give you a little more context.
If you don’t have time to watch all of Matt
Smith’s run just watch series 7b through
the christmas special.
If you really really don’t have any time,
just watch the 50th and the christmas special.
I did post a beginners guide but it’s really
just a cliff’s notes.
The truth is you could watch everything and
there would still be the novels, the audio
dramas and the comics.
So you just have to draw the line somewhere.
Really you should at least watch the 50th.
It was amazing.
Question 8 - Michael Jarvis asks Do you think
we'll see the return of Omega?
I don’t think so, and here’s why.
It’s mostly because the old things that
Moffat is bringing back.
Or at least the stuff that we know about right
now.
Is all stuff he’s either written himself
or stuff from his time as showrunner.
When it comes to classic who I think the things
they’re bringing back are mostly thematic
and visual.
Not so much characters but character traits
and the tone of some of the previous Doctors.
There’s a lot we still don’t know so it’s
always possible, but I think they also want
to introduce some new monsters and villains,
so bringing in someone like Omega would overshadow
any new things they brought in.
I don’t think they want to steal focus too
much.
That’s part of the reason the Master isn’t
coming back, that and scheduling.
Remember, John Simm has a new series that
he’s on called intruders.
It’s premiering right after Deep Breath
premieres.
Question 9 - James McQueen asks what’s your
favorite TARDIS interior?
I always like new interiors, so each time
I see a new one I think it’s better.
But if I had to pick I’d say the one I was
most excited about was John Hurt’s TARDIS.
He was billed as the War Doctor so I got so
hyped to see what a TARDIS would look like
during the Time War.
The Doctor changed himself to be more brutal
so his console would fit that personality
and function.
It looked like a colder version of 9’s TARDIS
with the Round Things.
I really loved that scene where Smith and
Tennant were trying to remember what the purpose
of the Round Things were and couldn’t figure
it out.
and Question 10 last one - Ejazz Hreidmarr
asks In the 50th Anniversary Tom Baker told
Matt Smith that he’d be revisiting Old Faces
soon.
What do you think that means and are they
going to follow up on it in series 8?
I think it could mean two things.
First seeing old faces as in Old Doctor’s
faces again in the next anniversary special.
I think we can all agree it was awesome seeing
Tom Baker show up and the 5ish Doctors short.
So he was talking about them coming back literally.
And I also think he was talking about Capaldi,
who we had not met yet.
Capaldi talks about his face being familiar
and somehow mysterious, like when he looks
in the mirror he recognizes the face as a
face he’s seen before but can’t place
it.
I think that will be one of the running plots
this series.
Finding out if the Doctor is re-using an old
face and if he is, why.
What’s the purpose in re-using a face versus
picking a new face.
All great questions, thank you for leaving
them.
Since I’ll have more time for bonus videos
eventually I’ll try to do more questions
in the future.
Like 15 or 20 versus 10.
Like I said, my next video will be the Classic
Who one.
I’ll try to post that by Saturday if not
earlier.
I have jury duty friday, yay.
So we’ll see.
In the meantime click here for my beginner’s
guide if you haven’t seen it and click here
to learn about the new trailer and all of
the episode titles this season.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!